[music]
>> This is again in Arabic one volume.
All the Kutub al-Sittah in one volume.
It's heavy, yeah?
Number Dar-us-Salam, the paper used is
Bible paper. Bible paper doesn't mean
Bible because the Christian missionary
use a very expensive paper which is thin
and light. So, they've used this
expensive thin and light paper. This
only in Arabic, it's not in translation.
Yeah, again.
It is
Kutub al-Sittah. Not Sihah al-Sittah.
If you can read
a Kutub al-Sittah, it's not Sihah
al-Sittah.
In India, it will be Sihah al-Sittah.
Kutub al-Sittah means six books.
Sihah al-Sittah means six authentic
books.
Only Bukhari and Muslim as a whole are
all authentic. In the other four books,
most are authentic. Most of them. So, if
someone quotes Abu Dawud, what are you
going to do? Yes, most probably, but you
have to check whether it's sahih or not.
For that, alhamdulillah, Sheikh
Nasiruddin Albani has done a very great
work.
For which Sheikh Nasiruddin Albani
also got the King Faisal Award in the
work of literature.
What Maududi got was in service of
Islam.
What Nasiruddin Albani got was in work
of literature. What he did that fine,
you know very clearly that everything in
Bukhari and Muslim is sahih. But if
someone quotes Abu Dawud, then someone
quotes Sunan Nasa'i, Tirmidhi, Ibn
Majah, what are you going to do? So,
yes, compiled Sahih Sunan Abu Dawud,
Da'if Sunan Abu Dawud, Sahih Ibn Majah,
Da'if Sahih Sunan Nasa'i. In his
compilation
of Silsalat [snorts] al-Hadith.
And that is one of the great works done
by Muhaddithin masha Allah in the last
century.
And amongst the recent scholars,
Sheikh Nasiruddin Albani is one of the
best as far as hadith is concerned.
So, he has done that. So, then if
someone quotes
Abu Dawud,
you have to check whether it is sahih or
not. Many a times, Abu Dawud himself
mentioned in bracket it is Da'if.
Now, his work wasn't to classify sahih.
His work was to collect, that's it.
He wasn't so much concerned whether it
is sahih or not. Or maybe he did little
research, didn't really do a lot. But
sometimes, he collected Da'if and
mentioned it as Da'if also.
But majority are sahih. If someone
quotes it as a hujjah,
how to offer salah and quotes from Abu
Dawud,
maybe true, may not be true.
So, then you have to check up whether it
is sahih or not. And Nasiruddin Albani's
Silsalat is very good reference. Again,
scholars may differ with Nasiruddin
Albani. He's a Muhaddith and I disagree.
He says it is sahih. When he said it is
sahih, it is alhamdulillah sahih. When
he said it is Da'if, you know, he was
very strict. No, no, he said Da'if, it's
not Da'if, it is sahih. Difference of
opinion are bound to be there in
Muhaddithin. We'll not go into that.
But
this is talking about the main books of
hadith. Then we have
Lu'lu' wal-Marjan we discussed.
That is a Muttafaq 'Alayh.
Then the new edition, the latest edition
which I'm doing in advance, I would like
to tell you
that whenever I spoke about Quran and
Sahih Hadith, and I'm doing it since
years,
Quran,
yeah, we have it.
No doubt.
Arabic Quran, you know, will be
pocket savior.
Arabic is much smaller Quran. No doubt.
When I say Sahih Hadith, can I bring
this full table to you?
And this hadith also, everything is not
here.
So, I used to always say Quran and Sahih
Hadith, but then
for brevity, we used to say, "Okay, two
main books
and the Silsalat Sahih of Nasiruddin
Albani."
What to do?
So, when I say Quran and Sahih Hadith,
where is Quran? Quran is in Sahih
Hadith.
So, okay, Sahih Hadith, okay, almost
all. Not almost all, but most of it's
there.
In Bukhari Muslim and the Silsalat Sahih
of Nasiruddin Albani. This concern was
there
a lot for me, but I used to use that.
Where is the Sahih Hadith? Okay, Bukhari
Muslim
and the classification of Sahih Hadith
by Albani. For me, that is
the I would say it's not everything, but
a good
because when you are debating and
someone wants to ask you, "What is
authentic source?" You have to say,
"This is an authentic source."
This was there troubling me for a long
time, but it was there. I had a
solution, part solution until I met
alhamdulillah, head of the department of
the Madinah University of Hadith.
That is
Dr. Sheikh Ziaur Rahman Azmi.
Professor Dr. Sheikh Ziaur Rahman Azmi.
He was the ex-head and dean
of
the hadith department
of Islamic University of Madinah.
And it was my pleasure and my honor that
I spent quite some time as to have
sessions with him for a few weeks. And I
learned a lot from him.
And many things I said come from the
sessions that I took with him.
Alhamdulillah. That is the reason even
if a Madinah graduate or a PhD comes, I
said I studied under your teacher.
So, what you can gain in that few hours
is a knowledge
which when we discuss, because I like
picking things which are difficult and
the just thing which is required for my
da'wah purpose. Same I had the pleasure
alhamdulillah to spend maybe about
three, four weeks with head of the
department of the lughah. That is Dr.
Fadl al-Rahim. Who became head of the
translation department of Mujamma at the
printing press. And I learned a lot from
him. And I really masha Allah review
these scholars. Alhamdulillah, after he
retired,
retired about more than 15 years back.
And
he's a scholar.
Alhamdulillah, in the last 15 years,
masha Allah, we came up with a project
which was headed by him
and supported by us
to compile all the Sahih Hadith
together.
Which no one, according to him, has done
in the history of Islam.
According to him,
there are approximately a million
hadith.
There are there a million hadith.
Out of a million hadith, if you remove
the duplicate,
as I said, his narration different,
if you remove the duplicate, it comes
down to approximately 60,000.
The approximate figures I'm talking
about.
When you remove the duplicate
from the million hadith, you are left
with about 60,000 hadith. From this
60,000 hadith, approximately
16,500
are sahih. Only 16,500
are sahih.
And
when you compile the Kutub al-Sittah
and remove the duplicate, like if you
remove the duplicate from Sahih Bukhari,
7,275 become 2,230.
So, if you compile all the hadith of
Kutub al-Sittah,
it will be tens of thousands of hadith.
You remove the duplicate altogether, it
comes to approximately eight to eight
and a half thousand
Approximate figures.
This is estimate being a scholar.
That means amongst all the Sahih Hadith,
only half are there in the Kutub
al-Sittah.
But these half are the most important
ones.
So, what he has been doing the search
after he retired for the last 15 years,
he had two PhD students with him. And he
started compiling. He said, "My mission
of life is to get this." And
alhamdulillah, we were together and we
supported the complete project masha
Allah.
And alhamdulillah, last Ramadan,
just about seven months back, it has
been completed.
It was completed one year before, but
revision and rechecking, etc. And it's
gone for printing just about two months
back.
It will be out
very soon.
It's not in the market yet.
But we have the soft copy.
And alhamdulillah, I have kept no
copyright on it.
So, this is the first time
in the history of Islam that all the
Sahih Hadith have been compiled. It's in
12 volumes.
It's been printed in 12 volumes.
It's mentioned there by Dar-us-Salam.
In this,
he has given his reasoning why he says
it is sahih or da'if.
In this book, there is additional about
3,000 hadith which are very popular
hadith, but they are not sahih.
For example,
there is a very famous hadith of
Muhammad Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam
that to gain knowledge, you can even go
to China.
It's commonly used by many Muslims. It's
a mawdu' hadith according to Nasiruddin
Albani. Mawdu'.
Not da'if also. Mawdu' means concocted.
There's a hadith which says that all my
Sahabah are like stars, you follow any
of them,
it is okay. It's also more than 100.
Very commonly used.
I still love you Emma.
I still love you Emma. I still love can
be there. There was still love in Sabah
without doubt. But the Hadith that
Muhammad
said I still love you Emma is a model
Hadith.
I still love you Emma.
How can I still love you Emma?
It cannot.
I still love you Emma. That's a
different question.
But it's not a real Emma.
So many a times I used to keep quiet. At
that time I wasn't so much into
analyzing Hadith. Yes, I say we were not
knowledgeable that time and neither are
we now. But now we are meeting people of
knowledge and asking them what is this.
So then we realize that Hadith is a even
more than you and I this is even say if
I'm talking about when we started the
hour.
More than 20 years back.
So this compilation mashallah it's
in 12 volumes which gives the names of
the rallies and everything and the
details.
Details means why it is say he why it is
say if this scholar said say he why it
is say if according to the ruling of
Professor Dr. Z I am an asthma whose
authority. You may differ.
You and I cannot differ but another more
this you can differ.
Same what I've done in the long project.
I was a little bit eager to get results.
I chose even the head of the department
of Jamia Imam of the Sunnah department
to do the same project simultaneously.
And that hasn't been completed inshallah
will be complete soon.
Started about 3 years back but will be
complete faster because we have a group
of teams associate professors. It's a
teamwork. His
analysis may be a little bit different.
Dr. Z I am an asthma says if not all
more than 99% is there.
Sheikh Faleh Saghir who was the previous
head of the department of Jamia Imam. He
says I'll only take from 10 books the
Kutub al-Sittah and some other books
which will contain 85% of the say Hadith
according to him.
So his version will be a little bit
smaller. May not contain 16,500
Hadith. May contain nine eight I don't
know.
Most of them are there. But Dr. Z I am
an asthma says any say Hadith you quote
it will be there. But it will be
mentioned there that this Hadith that is
there which says
it is in Bukhari and also there in this
and also in there this.
We give references.
Hard work.
It will not be like one two in Bukhari.
It will be there. Now if you read this
volume inshallah he says 99% I am a bit
more safe. I said more than 95. I like
being safe. So I said at least more than
95% and more than 95% even covers 99. So
they are debating.
I say more than 95% of the Hadith that
are
are there in Al-Jami Al-Kamil.
And the name that he gave to his book is
Al-Jami Al-Kamil fi Al-Hadith Al-Sahih
Al-Shamil.
In 12 volumes. Inshallah will be out
very soon.
Then he had made a mukhtasar version
without giving the arguments only giving
the names of the rallies in five
volumes.
Mukhtasar means
condensed. He's not giving the
arguments. He's not giving the famous
say if and more than you Hadith which
are counted as say he.
Only the say Hadith with only the
narration without the argument.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun
Rasulullah.
Muhammadun [music]
>> [singing]
>> Arju ridhaka ya
>> Allah.
>> Anta Rahimu ya
>> Allah. Habni ataka ya
>> Allah.
>> Antal Karimu
minkal afwu ya
>> Allah. Antal Azimu ya
>> Allah. Fikal raja'u ya
>> Allah. Antal Halimu
Ar-Rahmanu As-Sattaru Malikul Mulkil
Ghaffarul Wahhabul Mannanul Muta'al.
>> [singing]
>> Ar-Rahmanu As-Sattaru Malikul Mulkil
Ghaffarul Wahhabul Mannanul Muta'al.
>> [chanting]
>> Ar-Rahmanu
As-Sattaru Malikul Mulkil Ghaffarul
Wahhabul Mannanul Muta'al.